Thanks to graphene, ultra-high pitched sonar
is now possible.
Graphene you are like the Superman of materials.
Or…
Would sonar make it more like Batman?
I don’t know stuff about comics.
Hi science lovers, Julian here for DNews.
I’m sure the majority of you know what sonar
is but just in case, I’ll explain.
Sonar stands for SOund Navigation And Ranging,
and it involves sending out a sound wave and
bouncing it off an object.
Timing how long it takes to come back will
tell you how far away the object is, which
is the same principle as radar.
Humans use it mostly under water because the
mechanical sound waves travel well through
it, while the electromagnetic waves from radar
get attenuated by the water much more quickly.
People with satellite TV who lose signal on
really stormy days know what I’m talking
about.
Sonar is said to have been invented in 1490
when Leonardo Da Vinci stuck a tube in water
and listened to ships pass but really, a tube?
Does that count as an invention?
That’s just sloppy, Leo.
Anyway, sonar has been around long before
Da Vinci came along and invented everything.
Famously dolphins and bats use high frequency
sounds to echo-locate and communicate.
We’re talking really high frequency too.
A human can hear sounds from 20 Hz to 20,000
Hz, and that’s if they have amazing hearing
and are young and never go to concerts.
We hear best where human speech speech lives,
in the 1000 to 5000 Hz range, or 1-5 kHz.
Some species of bats can hear as low as 1
kHz too, but a bat’s hearing may be as high
pitched as 200 kilohertz.
Literally 10 times higher than humans.
It’s not easy for our equipment to detect
or emit sounds that high.
Dynamic microphones work when sound waves
vibrate a diaphragm, which in turn causes
a magnet to move around a wire and generate
an electrical current, and speakers work the
same way but in reverse.
The diaphragms in these mics and speakers
are usually paper or plastic, which aren’t
sensitive enough for detecting ultra-high
frequencies.
Now, thanks to the wondiferous material of
graphene, a huge range of frequencies can
be detected and reproduced.
It’s because graphene is so thin.
It’s just, say it with me now, one atom
thick.
Scientists at UC Berkeley realized this would
make it an ideal diaphragm, and have created
microphones and speakers that work well below
20 Hz and all the way up to 500 kHz.
Yeah, you thought you were bad, bats.
Now what?
Actually studying bats was one of the first
tests for these new microphones.
The researchers took them to a nearby park
to test them out and found the mics pick up
the bats chirps well across the spectrum.
Plus they’re so small they can actually
be mounted on the bats themselves.
Aside from studying bats, the mics and speakers
could have loads of other uses.
The speakers can emit sharp pulses at high
frequencies, meaning they can be used for
measuring distance much more accurately than
traditional methods.
The researchers envision a world where ultrasound
is part of your cell-phone’s arsenal for
communication.
I’m thinking that’s not creative enough
though.
What about a personal sonar device for the
blind?
Or since these graphene speakers are 99% efficient
at turning electricity into sound, compared
to the 8% efficiency of your headphones, why
not have some killer and lightweight portable
stereos?
The researchers even claim the sound waves
can penetrate objects like steel, something
radio waves can’t do.
If you can convert those sound waves into
an image…
X-Ray vision, anyone?
Let’s innovate, guys!
One company that’s innovating all over the
place is Intel.
With processors, wearables, datacenters, devices
on the internet of things, and of course,
in your Mac or PC, Intel is driving innovation.
If there’s Intel inside, you’re going
to have a better experience outside.
They’re creating breakthrough technologies
that make amazing experiences possible, and
they like us, so they make DNews possible
too.
Bat sonar is pretty incredible but nature
is an arms race, and some moths have evolved
a way to go stealth mode.
Check out the amazing story here.
How would you used these graphene mics and
speakers?
Do you have some ingenious use I didn’t
come up with?
Let us know in the comments, or facebook,
or twitter @DNews.
Subscribe for more, and I’ll see you next
time on DNews.